and you know I because I even say that
now as part of GTD we we use the phrase
mind like water you know like you have a
clear head you know and now the
mindfulness people you know that's no
that's a whole lot of what they're doing
now but I learned that 35 years ago
because in the martial arts there was a
lot of training about how you clear your
head
because if you're walking into being
surprised by four people in a dark alley
you don't want 2,000 unprocessed emails
banging around on your brain right you
need to be clear they need to be clear
so how fast can you get clear so
focusing on your breathing was the best
way to get clear because it brings you
present your breathing is current as
present so that's what and the
mindfulness people know that you know
that's what you if you focus on your
breathing you can't you're not in the
future you know in the past you're
actually in the present which is you
know from my experience at least with a
small isakki spiritual principle like
acceptance but acceptance has to be
right now you know can you not resist
whatever is current your current
realities what else do the martial arts
teach you yeah what was that it was that
the big thing it was that it was you
know certainly a lot about focus you
know if you're gonna if you're gonna try
to break through three inches of wood
with your hand you know it doesn't take
calluses it takes focus you know and
what you can't have is the thought of
wow that's going to hurt in your mind
you know you have to you have to already
see your hand through it so I learned
back then the power of sort of
visualization to begin with because
that's there was so much of that ability
to focus and a whole lot of that's
driven by your mind and so I learned a
lot of that and again in retrospect I
could say you know that a lot of that
was just great training you know about
how to do that in one of your TED talks
you said that you know a lot of GTD was
a bit like martial arts as and you're
doing these things that are
uncomfortable at first that are building
up a pattern that's gonna make you work
efficiently and people often ask Brian
why I call it a martial art and the
reason is because I mean it's really
kind of an art the art of how do I
manage the flow of life's work in my
commitments and that whole inventory
and you don't end that I mean how good
can you get it parenting how good you
can you get it cooking spaghetti how
good can you get it playing the flute
there's no end to any of those there's
no end to this either I'm still tweaking
refining
my life changes then how do I manage the
flow of that change in my life that
doesn't that never stops but the reason
I call it a martial artist because
martial deals with surprise it deals
with things coming at you you can't see
now that's in subtle ways true with
painting and dance and anything else
that's like you're dealing with you know
all kinds of other aesthetic forces I
guess but it's very much like from email
some thought that I wake up oh my god
they just fired me I just got hired I
just bought a house I just sold a house
I got divorced I just got married I just
had a kid I just discovered to have a
life-threatening illness so when those
those transition times in life are where
you come up against how well can I deal
with that how fast can I integrate this
new information accept it say where I
want to go now and refocus and
recalibrate that's really that's why
it's a martial art mmm so GTD is a
martial it is and you say before that
things are coming they're gonna be good
things they're gonna be bad things but
most of us aren't necessarily prepared
for the next thing because we're running
these endless loops in our head
well you're not prepared to deal with
them as effectively as you could if you
had a clear head
you're gonna tend to over and on to
react so see if we're sparring you know
Brian if we're sparring I'd love nothing
more than to get you upset because if I
can get you upset you will over under
react called a fake right and then I win
if I because if I can get you if I can
get you to over under react I can
control you so the idea of being really
really clear you know so that I can't be
I don't want to be controlled by
something now I'm not I'm not saying
control I control your kids or the
weather or your boss I mean good luck
I'm talking about having something under
control
like stable and stable and presence so
that you're not you're not worried about
the meeting you were just in you're not
worried about the meeting that's coming
up and that's what successful people do
they have it to where they can not under
or over react and that's how they have
quote-unquote success in their lives
well I think it depends on what you mean
by success yeah yeah sure I mean they
there's successful what does that mean
you know does it mean happy does it mean
just achieving desired results you're
just you know if you go on a vacation to
relax and you don't relax it's an
unsuccessful the occasion right so if
you're talking about I think the people
who are most usually the most effective
certainly the ones nicest to be around
the ones that are not over around or
reacting and they're just present you
talk to them and they're there yeah it's
big and popular now the meditation the
presence but this is something that
you've been thinking about for you know
yeah come on they live thousands of
years you know read read any of the old
text you know about just being present
they all you know they all talk about
that yeah and if you look at you know
some fighters you know I watched the UFC
a lot mixed martial arts and and a lot
of times the fighter will try to get in
the other fighters head and again get
them to overreact or under react and you
can see it plays out right in the ring
or in the cage and it's a bad night for
them and so that's why people should
think of their lives that way as and if
they can be in that present state the
non-emotional nonreactive state then
they can handle what's coming at them in
the way that they want to do it yeah
yeah